(twangy music)
(audience laughs)
(audience cheers)
(plane engine roars)
(intense music)
Lots of special events taking place
in honor of Comic Con yesterday
at the San Diego Library.
There was a Quidditch tournament.
(audience cheers)
Yeah.
Yes!
And trust me, when a bunch
of adults get together
to play Quidditch, there are no winners.
(audience laughs)
(laughs) There were people, I'm sorry,
there was a whole section
that was so happy.
(laughs)
"Conan likes Quidditch!
Why would he say it?"
Right now, they're hiding their brooms.
[Conan] I know.
White Walker is another name for?
A Trump Cabinet member.
(bell dings) (audience
laughs and applauds)
What superhero smells
too strongly of cologne?
Uberman! (bell dings)
Uberman, yes!
Will Smith, Joel Edgerton, Noomi Rapace,
Lucy Fry, and director David Ayer!
(upbeat music) (audience clapping)
The witch-hunting, demon-slaying brothers
Sam and Dean Winchester,
Jared Padalecki and Jensen Ackles!
(sci-fi music) (audience clapping)
(screaming)
What?
Oh!
Look who came crawling back!
Well settle in.
It's only two hours to San Diego.